mark down this date june 22nd 2021 the
major league debut of juan de franco
arriving in grand style rolls royce and
all to start his major league career
eduardo rodriguez 5 and 4 era up to
6-2-1
and just like that the rays get a base
runner
now battling for the raise and making
his major league debut
third baseman number five juan
franco has been baseball america's top
prospect in back to back years
and he draws the walk
everything away
up the second goes diaz and the rays
have two on and nobody out so the bases
are loaded with two outs
for francisco mejia one strike pitch to
mejia swinging a hardliner into left
backhanding his boguard throws to second
knotted time and the throw gets away
diaz scores here comes franco to score
and a rosa reign at a third up the
second mejia the rays have taken a
two-nothing lead
that's going to help
all right popper will it stay playable
diaz near the dugout he got there
made the catch just as he got to the
railing
deandi diaz
streaking over to the dugout railing
just in time
faces empty two outs and we go back to
the top of the order jaundi diaz
starting to like to throw his change up
more and more here it is again
and that will be stroked into right
center field and a long run and a slide
by santana comes up empty
renfro has to gather and gun he's on his
way to third here's the throw the tag
waiting and he is out at third base bad
baseball oh what new
diaz making the final out of the inning
at third base
so here we go that's a walk in a hit and
the table is set for the big boys jd's
10 for 18 against them with two homers
and five doubles
out of the ranger franco down into the
corner
santana into score here comes madugo
rounding
no play at home played he beats it
martinez all the way down to second he
continues to pick on yarbrough and this
game is tied yarbo is really on the
ropes and here is raffi first and third
they lead
number of throws
swinging a little blooper into center
field racing in kiermeier he dives and
makes the play tagging at third is jd
not nearly enough on the throw it's a
sacrifice fly for devers and it's 3-2
red sox but here is hunter renfro
right-handed hitter with power
swinging a high fly ball he jacks this
one to left center deep care meyer back
she is gone
home run hunter renfro
a two-run shot off yarbrough
and the sucks extend the lead to five to
two
franco against rodriguez
he swings and sends a fly ball back into
center field
santana
about 10 feet short of the track makes
the catch
brought a little excitement to the crowd
here on contact yes he did
on the ground and a diving stop walls
picks it up in the throat oh what a play
taylor walls
comes up with a dandy to get bogarts
with some help on the other end by yandi
diaz absolutely that ball was smoked by
bogarts we've already seen him go up the
middle in this ball game taylor walls
fired up and look at juan de franco no
one clapping more than he was
wider into left and that ball will be
caught the rogue arena had to go back
and then
stretch
to make that grab
and the rays get two on with
nobody out
and wander farco in search of his first
big league hit coming up
and he swings hits it high
and deep
and gone
broncos first of the big leagues will
tie this game
can you believe this curtain call
rodriguez out of the game josh taylor
another lefty enters for boston
he's talking about that time swinging he
put him away twice but he is fan two in
the inning
low fastball and here is franco again
[Applause]
one one another lighter in the left
that's gonna be in there
one hop to the wall
he's digging for two and the throw back
in will not be in time a double for
franco
105 off the bat and then off to the
races you can see him already thinking i
have got to get into scoring position
will the fans know his name
is 1-1
breaking ball and popped him up
drifting back hernandez coming in renfro
and [ __ ] finds it makes the play big
smile after that catch
i wore him out
1-0
high fly ball by raffy devers
headed to the warning track and now
coming in and that struck something up
there that struck a catwalk and drops
down and he romps into second base oh
wouldn't that be a beautiful thing oh
yeah oh my goodness this place oh he hit
run at second here's on a rent fro full
count pitch
ground ball third and he
go he got the tag
tried to get the tag but he ran away
from him
and he is out for running out of the
baseline debbers and the throw to first
was in time
and so renfro is out there
so the rookie walls will be next
02 again to the rookie walls
[Applause]
on the way
in there strike three at 95.
he got out of it
and debate we're tied five five
graves gets the lead off man aboard at
the bottom of the ninth inning
jandy diaz
a little tamper right side caremeyer is
tagged out the ball loose
and everybody's gonna be safe
no no
and it rolled knocked it right out of
his glove to xander at second base oh my
goodness oh this play is under review
and obviously a giant play
i'm going to call him out
outed second safe at first and a red sox
win a huge challenge
checks his runner diaz the 3-2
to meadows
and throws him with a breaking ball he
struck him out
and we're going on to the 10th inning at
the drop
runners lead at second and third the
pitch and this one gets by zanina he
gets a care and they got a chance he is
put the tag
on dalbeck
infield looking at turn two
as fairbanks
comes set with runners leading at the
corners and fairbanks ready runner first
goes the pitch swinging a miss strike
three throw to second it's a strike
about throw them out double play to win
the inning
and run us at second and third two and
one to raffy 2-1 swing hard ground ball
right side throw for a base hit rolling
down the line into the corner two run
score wong crosses the plate
and right behind him bogarts a two run
double for raffy devers and the red sox
take a seven to five lead and here's
renfro with nobody out and he swings and
lines one into right of base here rafi
hitting third here he comes here comes
the throw by lau it's up the line
another run scores and the red sox lead
at eight to five the fairbanks is having
a rough outing another runner at third
that'll be a wild pitch
we'll hit this one to right feel pretty
well struck backing up his low onto the
warning track here comes the run tagging
up
renfro is in the score and the red sox
are on top nine to five in the 11.
two down as
the runner goes to third here's the 3-2
ground ball the shortness should do it
bogart's up and over and the red sox win
this one and 11. they take game one
9-5 over tampa bay